76 mètres de long 13 m de large contre
renforcer en acier aluminium
ce yacht qui porte le nom du médecin
bactériologiste qui découvrit le bacille
de la peste
alexander steen a également été conçue
pour les explorations océanographique
échantillons
on connaît bien les herbiers de plantes
classiques mais on connaît moins bien
les herbiers d'algues comme celui là
donc avec les différentes variétés qu'on
a pu trouver sur notre route et chaque
chaque échantillon est identifié par sa
station et passeront par un code qui
permet de le tracer ses multiples
variétés d'algues ont été prélevés en
plein océan atlantique dans le cadre
d'une mission intitulée mission
sargasses transatlantique
une première expédition avait déjà été
initié en juillet sur la zone caraïbes
cette fois des programmes de plongée
scientifiques dans des conditions
extrêmes ont permis de révéler une
biodiversité exceptionnelle autour des
sargasses et images class in death arias
comme étant
très négative sur le littoral ce qui est
certainement vrai se retrouvent
ben disons un petit peu améliorée
puisque dans le milieu pélagiques en été
on observe un fonctionnement en
dispositifs de concentration de poissons
exceptionnel et on a récolté à ce titre
des images assez démonstrative
les observations sur place ont été
confrontés à des images satellites où
sont représentés des îlots de sargasses
les scientifiques s'interrogent sur les
déplacements et les échouages sur nos
côtes de ces radeaux de plantes sur la
surface des mers
la nouvelle maire d'essars gazon qui
s'est développée dans cette zone de
recirculation au nord de l'équateur 1
dans l'atlantique a été à l'origine
enrichi par des à des apports de
l'amazone et à partir de là on pense que
en 2011 il ya eu des conditions qui ont
fait que ya un basculement qui s'est
fait qui s'est opérée après on sait
qu'il ya aussi des années blanches
c'est-à-dire des années sans
prolifération de seria c'est ça pour
l'instant c'est pas encore bien
interpréter les sagas ce ne sont pas les
seuls temps forts d'une mission
scientifique qui prendra fin en 2020 le
programme monaco explorations lancées
par le prince albert verra se succéder
des scientifiques du monde entier des
missions aussi variés sur la
conservation de fork à madère où les
ateliers sur les tortues au cabo verde
ont déjà eu lieu mais d'autres aventures
attendent des scientifiques du lierse in
plus que jamais au chevet des océans